foreign
[Applause]
I've been asked a few times if Riley
would have done anything different or if
I would have done anything different an
honest answer is Riley would have done
the same thing a hundred times over
without it without question and I have
no regrets I would have encouraged him a
thousand times over
hi I'm uh Jim McCollum I'm Lance
corporal Riley James mccollum's father
there were so many facets to who he was
um he was a kind caring loving just
beautiful kid
but you had to be inside his Circle to
to uh to know that on the outside he was
he was a wrestler from about the time he
was four years old
um very abrasive
um you'd think he was mean
um but no he was a he was an outstanding
kid he was he was all boy
um growing up
and his older sisters made sure that
they tortured the heck out of him so he
[Music]
teach her him with he was always down
for and secretly enjoyed most of it one
time he would take like soft winter
gloves and cut all the fingers off of
them and so you know they'd be coming
down like halfway down his fingers and
he'd like sit outside wrestling
tournaments begging for change he got
along with adults more than he got along
with kids his own age for a long time he
was so smart and it got him into a lot
of trouble
he always knew what to say to get
out of trouble I was getting phone calls
constantly about hey Riley's not at
school today you know hey Riley was late
for school today and you just could
never be you could get mad at him but
you couldn't stay mad at him he he
always had a way to
to make you smile
watching him play video games of all
things but he would play war games on a
PlayStation
and you know it used to bother me that
he spent so much time playing the games
but he absorbed everything from him and
he actually learned a lot of history
he knew every war every battle every gun
every Skirmish we ever had who the
presidents were
that's one of my favorite memories of
him is just looking back
how engaged he was
and and just how it all intertwines and
put him to the place where he was when
he died
and on his 18th birthday I got a phone
call hey Dad I need you to come to town
uh and to sign some papers I'm enlisting
um this was before he graduated it's
like absolutely I dropped everything and
a pretty proud moment for me he wanted
to do it since he was three four years
old and he talked about it his whole
life we were just so proud we knew
that's what he wanted to do we were all
more shocked that he showed up to school
that day yeah of course he did
um he shared a lot I didn't think he'd
write as much as he did but he he wrote
a lot of letters home
um
and wow when gra after graduation when
we went out uh Royce and I went out to
his graduation and you could just see
there was a the chest was out chin was
out there was a a
Swagger
for a lack of better words
um
he accomplished something that he wanted
to do which he always found a way to do
through wrestling and everything but but
this one I think really mattered to him
and honestly from boot camp graduation
when we went to MCRD
um
to
the last picture we have of him in the
last conversation we had with him
it was boy to man in in that short short
period of time
um he definitely matured and became who
he was going to be I think the last
conversation I had with Riley he was
still in Jordan at the time and it was
just after the bombing of Israel
I really don't remember the depth of the
conversation
a couple weeks might have been three
weeks before they went to Afghanistan
his phone had broken
in uh
show the communication just wasn't there
but he would get on and he'd chat with
Gigi and uh
I know he was okay because that little
Green Dot by his name was was there it's
like all right you know he's good I
didn't need to talk to him I knew he was
fine and
you know I'd think about him but
one regret that I do have is there were
two other times the girls got on the on
a phone call with him
but I was at work and it's like I'll
catch him I'll catch him next time well
there there was never a next time I
actually called him
um
[Music]
on Facebook and I was at work and I
think she had shot me a message or
something and then I saw the Green Dot
by his name so I called him he had broke
his phone so it was either somebody
else's phone or he did have a computer
that he
um could video chat over Facebook with
us every once in a while so I was I
chatted with him for like 10 minutes
just kind of bsing and telling him I
miss him and I love him
when was I go shoot Riley like I have
you on the phone we should probably call
Royce and Dad so we hung up and then we
called on our family group so that they
could jump on and dad does that work
and I mean
you would never know it was gonna be
your last conversation
I should have stopped working you know
perspective what's more important
um hindsight man I should
I should have answered those calls
um they were already in Afghanistan
before we got noticed that they were
there they had already been there I
believe at least three days
uh when we found out that they were
there
yeah I was uh
just something in the back your head let
you know this is this is not going to
turn out good you're just seeing it all
unfold and what was happening and how
many afghanis were trying to get out of
out of Kabul in the in the just absolute
train wreck of you know people falling
off of the planes and trying you know
doing anything then you start to get a
grasp of how desperate the situation was
um
really leading right up to the day of
the explosion I got a call from my
friend and her husband's in the Navy
and she was like rice how are you doing
today and I was like man actually I was
like I'm having a really rough morning
and I was just complaining about stuff
and she goes okay well how's Riley like
what about Riley and I just started
crying immediately and I said what about
Riley
and that's how I found out about the
bombing I hadn't heard about it yet and
um and she told me what had happened and
I just I knew and I called Dad and
Cheyenne and I told them what happened
you know sometimes as you're going
through life you wonder
you know
the ups and downs and then the you know
button heads and everything you wonder
if you're doing the right thing or
should I have done something different
but now as I reflect it's like wow you
know he
he was really engaged and he was really
he did he wanted me to be proud of him I
hope he knows that I was proud of him
that's one of the things that I wish I
would have said a thousand times to him
um
um yeah honestly after he died that's
one of the things that haunted me the
most was God I hope he knows how proud I
am of him
Riley's a little girl Levi Riley Rose uh
she was born 18 days after Riley died
she is
the most beautiful little girl
um
I can look at her
and I see Riley the boy
and I see Riley the man in that little
girl is
just fascinating
he was so excited to be a father
when he was in Jordan he bought a little
tiger
and Riley would sleep with it while he
was in Jordan every night and he took a
rash and a crap for sleeping with a
stuffed animal but it meant something to
him and that little tiger made it home
with with his stuff so Levi's got that
tiger
that Riley got got it for her
when uh when we talked to Levi about
Riley
um
and I hope Gigi does the same
um
openly honestly
almost as if he's still here I want her
to know who her dad was good bad and
otherwise the funny stories
what a great man he was what a great
father he was going to be
I think being around us is the most
she'll get out of Riley
um because he obviously grew up with us
and became who he was living with us
tell the silly stories about him and how
funny he was and how smart he was and
what a turd he was sometimes and I mean
I think she needs to know everything and
how he became the man he did like the
only thing I can say about you know all
13 kids my son included and especially
for me it's my son that all 13 is
for the rest of my life I'm going to
make sure they're not forgotten
let the world remember
they weren't just Marines and you know
Army and Navy they were
they were all young kids absolutely
beautiful people and their stories need
to be shared